on
j'ai accepté de témoigner parce qu'à
l'époque où j'ai eu mon accident je
roulais énormément et je pense que je
voyais la voiture et la route de façon
générale comme un moyen de transport un
moyen de locomotion
quelque chose d'assez banal et le jour
où l'accident arrive on peut se dire que
qu'on ait commis une faute ou pas on
prend conscience que la voiture c'est
une arme on s'imagine pas en une
fraction de seconde la vie bascule du
tout au tout et je pense que c'est
important que les gens en prennent
conscience vraiment c'est pas rouler en
voiture que ça soit 50 à 80 à 110 km h
est pas anodin c'est vraiment pas anodin
et et on a sa vie la vie de ses proches
et la vie des autres automobilistes
finalement dans les mains à chaque
seconde
j'ai eu un accident de la route
qui s'est produit le 26 décembre 2012
une perte de contrôle banal sûr
une voie express équivalent de nos
autoroutes bretonne à vitesse normale
donc sans excès de vitesse
peut-être des conditions météo un peu
difficile ce soir là beaucoup de vent de
pluie faisait nuit alors heureusement il
n'ya pas eu d'autres véhicules impliqués
notre sujet eu de la chance aussi donc
pas d'autre victime je me suis retrouvé
à l'hôpital donc quatre heures après
en soin intensif et puis depuis peu dire
que l'état l'état physique et stabilisé
donc avec des déficits dans
l'appréhension des mains donc compliqué
de s'alimenter seul ou couper sa viande
les déplacements même en fauteuil
roulant si on peut le faire mais je ne
peux pas sortir par temps de pluie parce
qu'à partir du moment où je peux pas
serrer les roues je suis avec des gants
mais qui dès qu'ils aient des clients
sont humides et les roues aussi bas je
patine donc je ne sors pas par temps de
pluie ce qui en bretagne et pas
forcément très pratique
alors le jour où l'accident est arrivé
j'étais dans la fleur de l'âge on va
dire que j'avais 30 ans je venais
d'avoir mon deuxième enfant qui avait
deux mois après ma grande fille avait
deux ans et demi moi j'étais aussi dans
une carrière qui se lançaient plutôt
bien et puis
donc l'accident survient et puis baisser
je vais pas dire que tout est remis en
cause mais tout change tout change
d'office après l'accident je me suis
réveillée le lendemain après l'opération
du jeu bouger ni mes bras ni les jambes
on a un peu de mal à
réaliser je crois et pour être très
honnête j'étais
psychologiquement j'étais au fond du
trou
je crois même avoir dit que je voulais
pas rester à vivre comme ça c'était
vraiment ma pensée du moment je me
voyais janvier j'ai pas du tout l'avenir
dans cette situation dans ce nouveau
corps là qui réagissait plus 20 tout
simplement
et puis au fil des jours j'ai eu un peu
la chance d'avoir des récupération
motrice de commencer à pouvoir bouger
les bras d'avoir des petits signes aussi
dans les jambes de récupération donc ça
c'est prolonger cette récupération là
pendant vraiment les six premiers mois
après l'accident et puis depuis peu dire
que l'état l'état physique est stabilisé